good morning believe nation today we're
going to talk about how you can build
good habits you're gonna need to get
yourself some rituals right now every
one of you this room is controlled by
your rituals I don't just mean this one
I mean every morning you get up I know
your body I can look at your body right
now and I can guess your rituals some of
you your rituals to work out five times
a week I can see it clearly
four to six times a week it's obvious
because you couldn't look like that if
you didn't do that some form of workout
I don't care what's walking lifting
whatever some of you it's obvious that
lifting weights as part of you can see
by that man's muscles I know I know what
his rituals are because your life comes
from your rituals but you don't develop
the ritual you're kidding yourself how
many degrees me on this rage against AI
and there are rituals to put you in
state no rituals to take you out of
state
I know you all have big goals big dreams
big aspirations just like I do
you've got ambitions to become an
amazing person to build your career to
create to contribute to give to be an
awesome human being but all of that is
impossible without great habits setup if
you don't have routine and structure set
up in a way that will keep you on track
then you'll fall often and having new
goals without new habits is kind of like
you know having a new car without wheels
you know the habits are the wheels they
are the things that make you able to
achieve the goals so you got to have
good habits but the challenge for most
people isn't that knowledge I mean you
know you need to have good habits it's
you can't keep the habit going right
have you ever started it the new year
you're gonna get healthier and you start
that habit of working out wanna more
regular basis and then it goes away or
you say you know I'm gonna be more kind
and more patient and more awesome to my
partner my lover and you start being
nice for two or three days and then on
the fourth day you're a jerk you know
and you're like what what happened I
said I was gonna be nicer it's that you
didn't set up the most important thing
you needed to maintain a habit you have
to set up trigger moments to activate
your habits what do I mean by that well
let's say you want to become a better
person you know you want to become more
kind more patient more loving with
people now you can just set that
intention or write that down in your
vision and your journal or set up on a
vision board that you look at once in a
while but in day-to-day life it's not
enough you need things to trigger you to
remind you to be that particular kind of
person right it's almost like if you
could have a little angel speaking in
your ear all day long to tell you what
to do and how to be you would obviously
become better well that makes sense
well let's use that idea let's use that
idea by setting up alarms on our phones
that trigger us to do the very things we
need to do this can be so basic you're
gonna laugh and then also tell you how
I've literally taught this to fortune 50
CEOs and they said it was the one thing
that changed their life the most
dramatically so let's start with this
let's say I have a goal in mind let's
say you want to become
more present and calm throughout the day
again you could write that down on a
journal I'm gonna be more present and
calm you could meditate in the mornings
like today I'm gonna be more present and
calm and you could you could start out
with good intentions but those fall
apart without a trigger moment set up
throughout the day to remind you that so
what if you did this what if you just
set up on your phone three alarms during
the day with a label that said close
your eyes take ten deep breaths in
remind yourself to be calm so let's say
you're going through your day it's crazy
right it's 10 a.m. and also being your
phone goes off you look down and says
close your eyes take 10 deep breaths and
then again it happens at 2:00 o'clock
and again it happens at 6:00 p.m. and
again it happens at 8:00 p.m.
what's gonna happen you always look at
your phone don't you it's gonna go
throughout the day you're gonna forget
and the funniest thing is I've had so
many people do this worldwide we're
talking about hundreds of thousands of
people I've talked to do this hundreds
of thousands and they tell me all the
time of that that changed everything and
you'll think once you set it up that the
next day you'll you'll forget about it
know that alarm will go off you forgot
you set the dang alarm there it goes off
in your face you're like all right I'm
trying to be calmer and more present
close my eyes take ten deep breaths
reground myself here we go you can't do
it once a day if you have to have
moments throughout the day that trigger
you to enact to the new behavior I know
this makes sense to you but it's a
challenge for a lot of people because
they never set those things up so what
if you did it with an alarm so for
example for me on the opposite spectrum
I don't want to just be calmer and more
present
I want more energy throughout the day so
here's what I do one of my big trigger
moments is every time my butt hits a
chair I don't care if I'm on a plane or
I was like where we're shooting here I
wrote a lot of my books here I wrote the
motivation manifesto here I wrote the
charge here and if I'm going to write my
butt's hits the chair I grab my phone I
open the timer and I set 50 minutes
now at 50 minutes the timer goes it
starts buzzin and I look at that and I
go oh that's my trigger to get energy so
I stand up I go get some water I take a
glass of water and drink it down I do
some stretches and I do some exercise
just really briefly or I'm go for a walk
whatever it is but I'll do something
that usually takes just 2 to 5 minutes
then I'll sit back down I'll set that 50
min alarm and I'll work and what that
does is every 50 minutes it triggers me
to change how I'm physically moving it
changes my attention so that throughout
the day I'm continually refreshed so I
never have that 2 3 4 clock timer my ah
you know why because I've triggered my
day someone that my energy is maintained
throughout the day makes sense right
this could be as simple as let's say you
want to be healthier in your life okay
let's set up some trigger moments for
you in this way let's say every time you
drop off the kids on the way back to
that house you stop at the grocery store
and get some fresh produce that's just a
trigger it's like okay did one thing
drop kids off now tied to that triggered
from that action drop kids off is go to
health food store or let's say you want
to get healthier in the morning one of
the easiest ways to help people maintain
a better exercise program is this set a
trigger you wake up in the morning your
first action is to drink water put your
exercise shoes on might get dressed if
you're naked just saying so you get
dressed
put your shoes on you go downstairs or
you go to the gym and that's the trigger
you woke up you do these actions nothing
interrupts those actions that's the
action and you have to have those set up
one of my other favorite trigger moments
to set up is doorframe triggers what do
you know that when you walk into a new
room to have a psychological trigger go
off in your mind that you've associated
with that doorframe so let me give you
an example if I walk into my house at
night after light if I've been working
all day and I'm gonna walk in I'm gonna
see my lady
I have it so when I ever walk
through the doors of my house three
words repeat off immediately in my mind
because I've done it so many times
consciously I went to the door I said
the three words said three words said
the three words and I did this so many
times and now when I walk through a door
my mind automatically triggers those
three words and I remember to be those
three words
so what words would you love to have
describe you as a person that you would
be happy if that was how people
described you what would those words be
have those and now set them up in your
life I teach executives to do this as
well I have them have a doorframe
trigger when they walk into their office
in the morning as soon as they walk
through that door frame
they have boom three words go through
their mind about how they want to be
perceived as a leader I have them set up
another door frame every time they walk
into a meeting into the conference room
when they walk through the doors of the
conference room they have another three
words that trigger off for them and it
just reminds them how to be so these
aren't big crazy things a lot of people
that think they have to completely
change their life what would change your
life completely is setting up more
trigger moments and associations that
when you see something you do this that
when this action is taken then that
happens that when you have the
opportunity to set up alarms on your
phone you set them up so that you're
interrupted in your everyday life to
remind yourself to stick to the habits
to stick to the intention you do that
enough on a continual basis you'll find
yourself in so many ways completely
rejuvenated and I promise you'll stick
to your habits even more and once you do
that you know that everything changes
the best way to maintain a habit is not
to expect yourself to follow it at all
times
number two is to simultaneously
recognizing that adherence to habits
herbs and flows the problem the mistake
that people make is they say all right I
had this diet I just digressed therefore
I should just throw it all out and I'm
going to eat cookies for the next six
months because I had one cookie and I
think that is is flawed on a lot of
levels there are tools you can use like
lift which I'm involved with which was
incubated by the Twitter guys out of
obvious
but ultimately the the last point I'll
make is one new habit at a time the best
way to avoid abandoning new habits is to
only adopt one at a time and one of the
issues with cooking and this will be my
last plan so when people say I wanna
learn how to cook the typical trying to
adopt five or so new habits at a time
grocery shopping prep cooking cleaning
of course you're gonna fail so just
picking picking one at a time try to
make the new habits earlier in the day
okay it's a lot easier to take a habit
that you've already created and it's
already running and kind of move it a
little bit later than the day than it is
to create a new habit later in the day
so off for example if you want to focus
your time in uninterrupted blocks start
by focusing the first hour of your day
in an uninterrupted focused block every
single day where you're working on
something important make it a habit
make it a ritual give yourself a reward
of some kind for practicing the new
behavior each time you reward yourself
you reaffirm and reinforce that behavior
soon you begin to associate at an
unconscious level the pleasure of the
reward with the behavior you set up your
own forcefield of positive consequences
that you unconsciously look forward to
as a result of engaging in that behavior
or habit that you've decided upon what's
an area life right now that you really
want improve what's an area that's
important to improve it's your body's
great how about your career careers
great how about your relationship
intimate one especially or your kids or
your relationship with your creative
spiritual side of your life
or is it your finances figure an area
that really matters decide on that area
number one write down what your life is
like in that area right now specifically
as possible so you might say well I'm
13.5 pounds overweight you know whatever
the weight is whatever the situation is
or my body fats like this or I make up
exhausted in the morning and you write
the truth of where you are right now
so you're real clear or I'm not in a
relationship I say I want a relationship
but I I'm not in one I don't seem to
find them all the good ones
be gone as my belief you know and I
really do want one but I don't have it
whatever your definition well I'm in a
relationship and god I wish I wasn't in
a relationship I'm planning my escape
wherever you are or I have a wonderful
relationship we'd love each other but
there just isn't enough passion just
like the truth of where you are the area
you want to change what right how it is
and then the second step is that's where
you got to be really honest with
yourself what are the rituals that have
put me there because whatever results
you're getting even if you don't like
the results there's some rituals that
are keeping you in that place there's
some rituals of what you eat or don't
eat how you move or don't move how you
sleep or don't sleep there's some
rituals and the lack of variety or spice
or energy or focus in an area there's
something you're doing and it's usually
not one thing it's a bunch of little
things they kind of do consistently
whenever you think about getting in a
relationship whatever you think about
working out whenever you think about
money and get yourself in a state of
overwhelm you start thinking about all
the things you can't control just write
down all the rituals you have and then
here's the third step what do you want
what's your vision and be really
specific I want to be my fighting weight
I want to be the strongest I've ever
felt I want to be I'm gonna turn my
whatever it is be specific and then last
step number four what are the rituals
that'll get you there what would you
need it differently each morning if
you're gonna be that kind of energy that
kind of strength how would you have to
happen would you work out what days
would you work out what time a ritual is
something you do consistently usually at
a specific time so becomes automatic let
me tell you something willpower doesn't
last
but rituals can last a lifetime I bet
you have some rituals in your life right
now you've been doing for years even
though some of them don't serve you I'm
just saying wake yourself up make if you
want a new year and a new life you don't
need to start in January first start
today start with this little video and
just begin to see what happens and see
how easy it is to just do a few little
rituals don't do them all just do two or
three new things and you know what
happens you'll get momentum because once
you discipline yourself in one area life
you feel yourself doing in other areas
as well I always say something that my
original teacher taught me I always
remind people there's always two pains
in life there's the pain of discipline
or is the pain of regret and discipline
weighs ounces as my friend Jim Rohn
taught me
regret weighs tons you don't have regret
so right now what do you want to change
what's it really like one of the rituals
that got you there that will take a
little homework if you're not sure ask
the people around you they'll tell you
what your rituals are what do I really
want in depth or the rituals they'll get
me there and then get yourself to start
a few those actions and lock them in
place thank you so much for watching I
made this video because live life lovely
asked me to so this is a topic you'd
like us to cover in the next addition to
believe life leave in the comments below
and I'll see what I can do I'd also love
to know how do you build good habits
what do you do for me it's one about
first understanding that there is a
problem that I need to change I think
too many people walk through life
unaware of their limiting beliefs and
bad habits so versus awareness - is if I
want to build a good habit I add it to
my schedule I block off time and put it
in my calendar
I don't just try to rush in and say well
someday or today I'm gonna try to do it
I make time for it in my schedule and
then three I'll commit to somebody else
like I'm here filming on video day for
my channel because Jason my cameraman is
here I committed to him to come I've
committed to you guys to make videos and
when you commit to other people you're
much more likely to follow through so
awareness make time for it commit to
others that's how I built them I'm
curious as to how you build them leave
in the comments below I'm gonna join the
discussion thank you so much for
watching have an amazing day continue to
believe and I'll see you soon